>> Laura: BIG NEWS OUT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TONIGHT.
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS
ANNOUNCING THAT HE WILL NOT BE
APPOINTING A SECOND SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO REVIEW THE FBI'S
HANDLING OF THE RUSSIA AND
HILLARY CLINTON PROBE.
IN A LETTER TO THREE
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS, SESSIONS
NOTICE THAT SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
ARE ONLY APPOINTED IN
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND THAT, INSTEAD, HE HAS
ASSIGNED JOHN HUBER IN UTAH TO
CONDUCT A REVIEW OF THE MOST
HIGH-PROFILE CASES.
OF COURSE, AND "INTERMINGLE"
EXCLUSIVE, AND FIRING ANDREW
McCABE OF THE FBI, JUST DAYS
BEFORE THE RETIREMENT, CITING AN
IG REPORT, THAT HE LIED UNDER
OATH.
THE PUBLIC STILL HASN'T SEEN
THAT REPORT, BUT JOINING ME NOW
ARE TWO MEN WHOSE OFFICES HAVE A
COPY OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
COPY.
LET'S BRING IN, FROM COLUMBUS,
OHIO, JIM JORDAN, AND WITH ME
HERE IN THE STUDIO,
NORTH CAROLINA CONGRESSMAN,
MARK MEADOWS, ALSO REPUBLICAN.
LET'S START WITH YOU,
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN, WHAT IS THE
HEADLINE THAT IS GOING TO COME
OUT OF THIS INSPECTOR GENERAL
REPORT?
>> WELL, WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WILL
COME OUT OF THAT, BUT WE KNOW
ABOUT ANDREW McCABE, HE DIDN'T
LIE JUST ONCE, HE LIED FOUR
TIMES, FOR GOOD TIMES, HE COMEY,
TO THE OFFICE OF FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY, AND LIED UNDER
OATH TO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
REMEMBER, THIS IS ANDREW
McCABE, DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
FBI, ANDREW ANDREW McCABE, THE
TEXT MESSAGES BETWEEN PETER
STRZOK AND LISA PAGE, TALKING
ABOUT THE INSURANCE POLICY IN
CASE DONALD TRUMP WAS ACTUALLY
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
SO THAT IS WHY THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT, IT WASN'T ONCE,
TWICE, FOUR TIMES HE LIED ABOUT
LEAKING INFORMATION TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" ABOUT
THE FBI.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN MEADOWS,
HE WAS ADAMANT IN THE OP-ED THAT
HIS CAREER SPEAKS FOR ITSELF,
THAT HE WAS AUTHORIZED TO SPEAK
AS HE DID TO THE PRESS, AND YET
YOU GUYS ARE SAYING HE LIED FOUR
TIMES.
>> I THINK IT'S NOT OUR WORDS,
IT'S ACTUALLY THE INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION WAS DONE BY HIS
COLLEAGUES.
WHEN YOU READ IT, IT'S NOT ABOUT
POLITICS.
YOU BROKE THE NEWS, ACTUALLY,
YOU BROKE THE NEWS RIGHT HERE A
LITTLE OVER A WEEK AGO NOW, AND
WHAT WE ARE FINDING, EVERYBODY
SAYING, THIS IS POLITICAL IN
NATURE, WHEN YOU READ THE
REPORT, YOU SEE IT IS NOT
POLITICAL, BECAUSE UNDER OATH,
CERTAINLY WITH THE INVESTIGATION
CERTAINLY WITH THE INVESTIGATIO
INVESTIGATION, A REAL CRIME.
HERE IS WHY IT IS CRITICAL.
ATTORNEY GENERAL SESSIONS, JUST
TALK ABOUT EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES, HOW MUCH MORE
EXTRAORDINARY WILL YOU BE, YOU
FIRE THE CENTRAL PLAYER IN THE
INVESTIGATION, THAT IS ONE
CRITICAL COMPONENT.
WE NEED TO HAVE THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
I DISAGREE WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, I CAN TELL YOU
TONIGHT, I WENT THROUGH AND
VIEWED SOME REDACTED THINGS THAT
WERE GIVEN TO OUR COMMITTEE, AND
ON SEVEN PAGES, THERE WERE 12
MATERIAL FACTS -- MATERIAL
FACTS, NOT JUST NAMES --
MATERIAL FACTS THAT WERE OMITTED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
IT IS TIME THAT THEY COME CLEAN
AND GIVE CONGRESS WHAT THEY
NEED.
>> Laura: 12?
>> 12 MATERIAL FACTS.
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT IS, YOU
KNOW THE NEWS BROKE ABOUT THE
MEETING THAT HAPPENED WITH
DENIS McDONOUGH --
>> Laura: THE FORMER
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF FOR
BARACK OBAMA.
>> THAT WAS REDACTED.
BUT IT DIDN'T STOP THERE.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE MULTIPLE
REACTIONS THAT HAVE TAKEN PLACE,
THIS DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
NOT COMPLYING WITH THE SUBPOENA
RESPONSIBILITY WE HAVE IN
CONGRESS.
FOR THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
SUGGEST THAT THERE IS NOT ENOUGH
THERE IS EXTREMELY
DISAPPOINTING.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN JORDAN,
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOUR COLLEAGUE,
CONGRESSMAN MEADOWS, IS SAYING
THAT --    -- I MEAN, THERE IS A
REASON TO REDACT INFORMATION,
WHETHER IT WAS A RELATIONSHIP
WITH JUDGE CONTRERAS,
RELATIONSHIP ABOUT McDONOUGH.
>> WE GO IN THE ROOM, IT IS
RIDICULOUS, BUT MARK IS EXACTLY
RIGHT, WHEN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WRITES CONGRESS AND SAYS, ONLY
UNDER EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES TO BE APPOINTED
SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL, WELL,
HOW 'BOUT THESE STATS, LAURA?
JAMES COMEY HAS BEEN FIRED,
DEPUTY DIRECTOR ANDREW McCABE
HAS BEEN FIRED, JIM BAKER,
FORMER CHIEF COUNSEL OF THE FBI
HAS BEEN DEMOTED AND REASSIGNED,
PETER STRZOK, FORMER DEPUTY HEAD
OF COUNTERINTELLIGENCE HAS BEEN
REASSIGNED, AND LISA PAGE,
FORMER FBI COUNCIL, HAS BEEN
DEMOTED AND REASSIGNED.
IF THOSE AREN'T EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES WARRANTING A
SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE HECK IS.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL KEEPS
POSTPONING THIS.
EVERYBODY KNOWS WE NEED A SECOND
SPECIAL COUNSEL TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS.
HOW CAN MR. HUBER -- I DON'T
KNOW MUCH ABOUT MR. HUBER, HE'S
PROBABLY VERY GOOD -- WE HAVE
ALL OF THIS PFIZER ABUSE WITHIN
TOOK PLACE, YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL, I HOPE
JUST JEFF SESSIONS FIGURES THIS
OUT.
>> Laura: THIS IS WHAT ONE OF
YOUR CHIEF CRITICS ON ANOTHER
NETWORK SAID ON THE QUESTION.
>> WAS THERE EVER A STRONG CASE
FOR APPOINTING A SECOND SPECIAL
COUNSEL?
>> NO.
AS FAR AS I COULD TELL, MOST OF
THE ACCUSATIONS AGAINST THE FBI
WERE GOING TO LUNATIC CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, JUST NOT GROUNDED IN
ANYTHING, AND I THINK THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL DID AN
APPROPRIATE THING HERE.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN MEADOWS?
>> WE LOOK AT THE FACTS, THE
FACTS SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES,
LAURA.
WHEN WE ARE LOOKING AT, IS IT A
MATERIAL FACT THAT PETER STRZOK
HAD A RELATIONSHIP WITH A FISA
JUDGE AND THEY CONCEALED IT,
YES.
IS IT A FACT -- AND WE NOW KNOW
THAT THE INVESTIGATION ENDED --
DONALD TRUMP STARTED LATE JULY,
THERE WAS A MEETING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, THEY SAID
THE WHITE HOUSE IS LEADING THIS.
>> Laura: I THINK A LOT OF
FOLKS MISSED THAT WHEN THIS
HAPPENED THE OTHER DAY, THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE IS LEADING.
>> WE GOT TEXT MESSAGES THAT
WOULD SUGGEST THAT YOU PAID
WITHIN SEVEN DAYS OF THAT, WE
HAD A MEETING WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE, CHIEF OF STAFF,
WE CAN'T DRAW A CONCLUSION, BUT
WE CAN CERTAINLY LOOK AT THE
FACTS, AND THE FACTS DO SPEAK TO
FURTHER INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: WHY CAN'T HE BRING
McDONOUGH AND?
>> I THINK THAT WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE THING TO DO, BUT
IT'S NOT JUST THERE.